good evening and welcome to a special
edition of tucker carlson tonight
in one of her first official acts as
vice president back in february kamala
harris decided to declare what she
called a national
emergency and right away that seems
strange normally it's the president's
job to declare national emergencies
the vice president's job is to oversee
vice just kidding we're not actually not
sure what the vice president's job is
but it's definitely not that
but kamala harris did it anyway in the
pages of jeff bezos's personal newspaper
the washington post
this new national emergency kamala
harris informed us is quote
the mass exodus of women from the
workplace
apparently there are still some women in
america who secretly prefer to raise
their own children rather than toil away
like worker bees for some soulless
publicly traded corporation
wall street is upset about that of
course so kamala harris sounded the
alarm
our female workforce emergency she wrote
demands
a national solution well five months
later we are sad to tell you that that
crisis is still ongoing there are women
even now who have chosen to skip the hr
department's latest zoom call and
workplace diversity initiatives
and are instead reading their children a
bedtime story and that's a tragedy
and honestly kamala harris hasn't done a
lot to help
in fact there is now a mass exodus of
women from her
office the toxic masculinity is coming
from inside the house
this week politico reported several top
female hera staffers have
quit after they say they were abused
quote it's not a healthy environment and
people often feel mistreated said one
it's not a place where people feel
supported but a place where people feel
they're treated like crap
as politico put it harris's team is
experiencing low morale
porous lines of communication and
diminished trust among aides and senior
officials
and then the article of course goes on
to make the usual excuses for all of
this
quote black women are subjected to
standards that men often don't have to
clear
right in other words because kamala
harris's father came from the caribbean
it's okay that she's a monster to work
for got it
hope that's comforting to the women
whose lives she's wrecked
we do see a pattern here though first
kamala harris takes charge of a problem
she doesn't really understand
and then she makes it worse let's help
women in the workforce she says
then proceeds to drive women out of her
own office
let's fix the border crisis she says as
the wave of illegal migrants becomes a
tsunami
here take this vaccine she tells you it
works perfectly
then she turns to kiss her vaccinated
husband while wearing a surgical mask
on one level it's hilarious to watch all
this they tell us that kamala harris is
very impressive
but look at her she's a joke she can
barely get through the day
she has no idea what she's doing but you
can't say that out loud
shut up and accept kamala's dominion
over you that's the new rule
point out that she's a power hungry
buffoon posing as a competent adult and
they will
instantly denounce you as a racist now
they do that because it works
a lot of people particularly the news
media still find the idea of being
called a racist
the scariest thing they can imagine
scarier than dying
so they will do anything to avoid that
including ignoring kamal harris's
obvious mediocrity
so as a result they barely cover her and
we're going to spend the next hour
filling that gap kamal harris may be one
of the least impressive people in public
life
but on some days it feels like she's
running our country anyway
last month the president of mexico of
all people made that point
[Music]
um
[Music]
amlo is not the only one the president
of the united states
calls her president and in this country
voters have come to the conclusion that
in fact she is
the trafalgar group is one of the only
polling companies worth paying attention
to at this point
they got the last election almost
exactly right when few other firms were
even close
tonight we've got exclusive new polling
from trafalgar that shows
who americans believe is actually
running the federal government
in a survey of likely voters the
majority of american voters said joe
biden is not really in charge
and it wasn't simply republicans who
thought that a third of democrats say
biden is not actually in charge another
10 percent weren't sure which is pretty
much the same thing
it's hard to believe there have ever
been numbers like that in american
history about the president
what do they tell us they tell us that
the media storyline the one here every
day joe biden's fine he's just got a
really bad stutter relax
isn't actually fooling anyone but not
for lack of trying
outside of this channel no one on
television is allowed to say what seems
obvious which is that biden can't really
do his job
that's forbidden precisely because it's
true
but joe rogan doesn't work on television
he hosts a podcast so he can say
whatever he wants
and recently he did
we're unhinged yeah in a lot of ways and
we're not anchored down by a real leader
you know we don't really have a real
leader in this country anymore
yeah and you could say joe biden is the
president he's our leader and you you'd
be correct on paper but
i mean everybody knows he's out of his
mind he's just
he's barely hanging in there
well exactly we don't say a lot about
joe biden's decline on this show partly
because it's depressing and partly
because our default position
always is to respect old people
especially when they get a little soft
as we all will if we live
long enough so it's bad karma to mock
them for it
but in biden's case and he's the
president it's demonstrably true and
everyone knows that including his family
so the question is
who's really in charge if joe biden
isn't and increasingly it seems like
kamala harris is running things
if you believe in democracy this is a
problem
no large group of people has ever
signaled the desire to put kamala harris
in control of the country
just the opposite in fact at the height
of the last democratic primary season
most of her own constituents told
pollsters they wanted her to drop out of
the presidential race
only seven percent of democrats in the
state of california thought their
senator kamala harris
should be president of the united states
so the people who know her best
have the least respect for her but she
got the job anyway
entirely by default here's the president
democrats thought they were voting for
employers can't find workers i said yeah
pay them more
this is an employee's
employee's bargaining chip now
what's happening
what was that well you know exactly what
it is but they're pretending that's not
what it is if you look at some of the
wide shots
in that tape you'll see the usual
propagandas from state media pbs and
others smiling and pretending oh it's
totally normal
but it's not normal at all that's the
president of the united states this is a
huge and dramatic change to our system
of government
biden senility means an awful lot of
power for kamala harris
and that's why we're spending the next
hour talking about her
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else